honte à découvert nous les français
voilà dans notre dame de paris
donc ce soir on va cueillir plein de
gens voilà qui ont fait des comédies
musicales tous les chroniqueurs sont en
personnages de comédie musicale et on va
accueillir pour commencer la chanson qui
t'a fait connaître bien entendu on vient
de la chanter ensemble et on accueille
quasimodo frollo esmeralda à votre avis
qui fait quasimodo en basset verdès
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
sur la vie de ma mère sur la vie de ma
mère se sont mis en oeuvre et montrez
moi j'ai presque envie de tout envoyer
faire du stop faut voir si quelqu'un te
crois oui madame c'est pourquoi et à
quel sujet merci voilà venez là allez
merci merci je suis fait rouler ce mois
rien
nice est 2 doigts sous les caisses
quitteront tuffreau mais il faut te
calmes et jean pierre mocky vous
connaissez isabelle oui elle est jolie
ah bah ouais les jolies et sa bosse un
bel hommage mais moi j'adore jean pierre
mocky j'adore sa fille j'adore toutes
les familles et ben voila si les filins
à travers bercy ça va lui faire plaisir
merci j'aime pas si je voudrais mais
j'adore jean pierre mocky allez on va
passer maintenant à j'adore mozart
l'opéra rock
c'est une de mes préférées la cin sauf
l'assasymphonie l'assasymphonie
géraldine maillet qui t'habite nous
[Applaudissements]
je
shu
est ce que quelque part entre ça et le
voilà merci cap car mon chéri et tu t'en
fais ce que tu veux
enfin c'est garde quand même merci
elle adore ça la faisait remarquer fait
j'adore ce que chaque folie dans toutes
les comédies musicales les mecs quand
ils marchent marchent comme ça ils sont
comme nous
franchement le gard bouclé quatre tombes
des musicales pourquoi tous les mecs
dans les comédies musicales
même quand tu marches qu'on n'y a pas de
musique faut que ça mais kate au québec
sont toujours là tu vois ils sont
maintenant les gars pourquoi si c'est
quoi c'est normal c'est quand je regarde
gilles verdez comme si je me dis comment
j'avais quand même une touche très
similaire mais tous comment on sait pas
bidonné pendant le show dans les gens
pleuraient zinc quand même comme on a
fait ce qu'il dit moi qui parle la kippa
l'air il ya un interprète
sauriez couper les micros merci je crois
que je crois que c'est ces questions en
coulisses à l'est elle est née au maroc
le pays du soleil bien sûr
alors forcément valérie bénaïm est
aujourd'hui le roi soleil
[Musique]
/
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me direz pas du tout loin celebrate
oshawa tu vas pas nous faire des shows
sont aux abois soleil non mais sans
rigoler mais quelle d'alcan alors
justement emmanuel moire qui sera dans
la deuxième demi-finale tout à fait
samedi soir et sera là avec une sublime
chanson merci pas faire des briques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ensuite ils nous viennent tout droit des
états unis des states voici sandy et
dany degryse sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
adama dahico la montagne a tué les trois
côtés sans rigoler et baisser les
scellés oui ce soir naïade a pour tous
les goûts lamela la seringue hall et la
salle est là là c'est vraiment que je
crois ça le fasse tout ce qu'on aime est
réuni dans ces trois femmes mais je dis
et la quenelle alors voilà c'est bon là
alain chamfort là ce avait été
exceptionnellement un champ et vous
pourquoi vous danser au ralenti bassila
moscato de fou sans déconner allez on va
cueillir maintenant le dernier couple
puisqu'elle a déclaré sa femme un
matthieu delormeau
il ya plus on sachez qu'on n'a plus
aucune nouvelle c'est vrai depuis que
francesca dit qu'elle est amoureuse de
matthieu delormeau matthieu delormeau a
disparu donc je lance un appel
mais si vous voyez matthieu delormeau de
près ou de loin ont n'hésitez pas à nous
appeler surtout n'intervienne agissait
pas seul
leur cerveau n'est pas y aller
sabah séjour me et francesca qui nous
font remous et juliette sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'est bon
ces morts là bas
merci vous ne tenez là vous oui non mais
sans les bâtonnets bondir et marilyn
manson féroce le gaffer roth & the gang
depuis quand romeo se jette par terre
toute la journée sur juliette ça qu'on
peut plus ouais c'est elle qui me dira
sera la soirée avec quatre là on en fait
vous êtes là bas oui j'ai fait en fait
delfino change en fait vous êtes là bas
oui mais voilà la balance est pas du
tout les trois drôles de dames
là c'est plus tôt ou mettez là battez
cherchez l'erreur merci qui doit alors
voilà on va faire tout de suite un jeu
qui doit retourner au bois de boulogne
[Applaudissements]